I'm always thinking about fried chicken
today we are trying KFC's new chicken
and waffles I did have concerns about a
fast-food waffle yes waffles I feel like
a waffle is best fresh because you get
the crispy and gaddafi well I love KFC I
grew up with it those biscuits though
are actually my favorite part of 53 yeah
I'm the type of person I sit down at
breakfast I'm just like indecisive do I
want savory do I want sweets and then I
figure out chicken waffles was the thing
I like I get the best of both worlds
what oh my gosh if we were sweet and
savory which one I want to be sweet and
which one would be savory I think that
you're the sweet one chicken time
check-in time it comes in its own little
guy mm-hmm so far it smells pretty good
it smells so good yeah oh the waffles
still a little crispy we're gonna have
some mrs. Butterworth's syrup is this
enough syrup certainly not I need three
of these yeah I am surprised though that
this isn't like an actual piece of like
fried chicken it's like a tender you
know versus like a leg
you know yeah I prefer the gender I am
that kind of chicken and waffles guy I
don't like the bone cuz I feel like it's
distracting I want to get right to it
yeah okay so the waffles very thick it's
like oh my god why is it a brick you
could build houses out of this waffle
it's big so I'm gonna stack this chicken
over the waffle and just do a light
drizzle that is a movie word that was
like you get that great rizal right
there this is like a commercial that's
why I was born to do cheers Cheers
[Music]
okay dang Google waffle hmm
Christian is tasty the ratio you should
eat this a lot of chicken is very small
piece of waffle I just didn't it yeah
the chicken is crispy the waffle is
buttery the syrup can't go wrong with
this syrup it's just butter I mean it's
koc check out okay okay KFC you know
chicken is pretty good there's not
greasy and I really thought it was gonna
be grease you hope you got like a little
less dense with them what what the
waffle maybe little area you know maybe
bigger and thinner there's only five
dollars
oh wow this is a good value I think
guarding at 5:49 if you have like a
craving for chicken and waffles I could
see this fella yeah but you don't want
to be fancy yeah this is like super
cheap if you go to a sit-down restaurant
order chicken waffles it's like at least
twelve thirteen bucks yeah the more I
eat it the more I like it there Colonel
Sanders if you're out there and Mrs
Butterworth I know that this might be
just a short fling but for our sake make
this eternal love in holy matrimony
[Music]
you